hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to reading your tweets now I
noticed something very peculiar about
Twitter recently
whenever I or anyone with a lot of
followers would reply to someone on
Twitter it could be a normal everyday
conversation whatever it was the other
person would invariably freak out and
the freak-outs range wildly from the
mildly deranged what the [ __ ] to a
complete disregard for the English
language limit that footage and I think
it's become like a little game inside
the community to see who can freak out
the most when they finally get that
reply that they've always wanted and I'm
not knocking it I'm now I'm not putting
it down in any way I think it's actually
quite hilarious even though in my mind I
imagine that the tweet says and yet
they're sitting on their toilet just
like I'm screaming oh my god I'm
literally dying and I thought what
better way to celebrate this rather
strange way of celebration than to read
these absolute bonkers insane tweets
live to you it's not live this is
prerecorded icon bleating Oh Timur [ __ ]
- for Faust mmm scream amazed you [ __ ]
uh chief Nicky mattered I'm shook I can
antipas gizzard what macro just George's
tweet Tunes to me Britney liked your
tweets mark oh my god oh my god
my Todd I can't Birgit a Freeman and
what the cut I'm screaming dude I know
I'm screen ever dude thank you I'm
Shakib oedema famine didn't I'm on my
floor kidand d mark I can are such as
cousin dick Aggie such an emotion God
were huh
no why [ __ ] I went wick specs it that
I'm about heat to crew what the foutch
rumery
I'm squeaking I'm so happy why I'm
literal to cry on the shisha jizz [ __ ]
Oscars consistent and no I came out I
meet you Ray J dead today
Crisco should the the Cleveland Lou oh
my Fahd I can't believe I'm not okay our
view sucks
Kim's breathe I'm brain I'm [ __ ]
screwy up here I can't believe okay so
that was just a sample of the freak outs
that I've seen on Twitter I've seen way
worse and I've seen way bigger than that
but I'm not gonna bother reading
paragraphs of random letters but this
was a lot of fun and I can totally see
why you guys would freak out when your
favorite youtuber responds to you on
Twitter that's totally cool but also
remember that we're just real people all
of us youtubers were just real people so
if we ever meet in person don't spend
our only interaction with each other
shouting in my face that you're
squeaking sorry don't mind that it
dropped me gerbil so I don't think I'm
gonna be doing another one of this
specific type I don't want to read all
freak outs all day long because that
would get very boring very quickly with
me to spouting Sims language up here on
the video but thank you everybody so
much for watching I will do more of
these reading your comments style videos
in the future but I like to mix it up a
little bit so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye